viruses are essentially protein packages
surrounding genetic material they can't
survive without a host and it's
debatable whether or not they're even
alive we don't have time to get into
that argument here but what we will do
in this video is examine some of the
Tsarskoe of two proteins the virus
responsible for the disease Kovan 19 by
now you've probably seen many images
like this one these artistic renderings
of coronaviruses coronaviruses get their
name from the spikes that protrude from
the surface of a viral envelope that
sort of resemble a solar corona these
spikes are actually the proteins that
bind to human cells and allow the virus
to infect them amazingly we already have
a lot of information about these spike
or s proteins the proteins are similar
to other members of the corona Verde
family
so researchers were able to build on
that knowledge and rather quickly create
the structures that will learn about
here we'll begin with a protein
structure that was solved by cryogenic
electron microscopy or cryo e/m if we
move from this view looking down at the
viral membrane the spike protein begins
to appear less triangular and we can see
it has a roughly cylindrical shape
notice that it's heavily glycosylated
during viral replication it uses our
body's own enzymes to covalently
attached sugars to asparagine side
chains near the protein surface it's
thought that glycosylation plays a role
in protecting the virus against our own
immune system as we zoom back out we're
now looking at the ribbon diagram of the
protein and if we color the Alpha helix
E's pink and the beta sheets yellow we
see a section of alpha helixes running
the length of the spike protein for the
most part the beta sheets are
concentrated on this end which is where
the spike protein fuses with a cell to
infect it this
protein is actually made up of three
intertwined chains that have identical
amino acid sequences each of these
chains is called a pro tumour however
the proto Murs do not have identical
three-dimensional confirmations let's go
back to our original color scheme we can
see the conformational difference in the
pro tumors by examining a section of the
spike protein that is critical to the
viral life cycle the receptor binding
domain or RB d the RB D is where this
virus binds to an enzyme on the host
cells surface enabling it to fuse with
the cell and transport viral genetic
material inside two of these R biddies
are in a Down conformation in the
structure let's color these yellow
however one of these are B DS is flipped
up this up conformation is higher energy
poised to bind to the cellular receptor
and result in fusion it's thought that
when the spike protein binds each of
these are b DS shifts into this less
stable up conformation our own peptide
bond breaking enzymes called proteases
can cut the spike protein at specific
sites and conformational changes in the
spike protein enable fusion to occur a
different research group published a
crystal structure of just the receptor
binding domain of the spike protein will
keep the RB d colored white in this
structure the RB D is bound to
angiotensin converting enzyme 2 also
called ace 2 which is the receptor on
our cell surface that the corona virus
binds to cause fusion notice these
structures are heavily glycosylated as
well let's hide the sugars in this model
so we can focus in on some of the weak
binding interactions that hold the RB d
and ace 2 together for example we have
an extensive hydrogen bonding network at
the RB d
a Stu interface involving these two
tyrosine residues this tyrosine
sidechain is also hydrogen bonded to the
carbonyl of this asparagine sidechain
which in turn bonds through its NH
hydrogen atom to the carbonyl of this
glutamine on a Stu moving along the ACE
to alpha helix we have a glutamate side
chain which is deprotonated at pH 7.4
and a lysine residue that carries a
positive charge at that pH these
residues are both involved in hydrogen
bonding with the Amadou of a glutamine
sidechain notice that these hydrogen
bonds are relatively short owing to the
strong hydrogen bonds that can form when
charged amino acid side chains are
involved in this region we have
extensive hydrogen bonding we see some
between amino acid backbone atoms and
some additional hydrogen bonds among
polar and charged residues like the
hydrogen bonds of this tyrosine with a
negatively charged glutamate side chain
and a positively charged arginine
sidechain overall characterization of
the spike protein is super important
because this paves the way for vaccine
development if we're able to prime our
immune system by introducing small
harmless peptides that resemble the
spike protein our immune system can
recognize and build up antibodies
against it protecting us against Kovan
19 infection in the future also knowing
what the RB d binds to could help us
develop treatments that tie up the virus
by binding it outside of the cell before
it's able to fuse and cause infection if
the virus does undergo fusion viral
genetic material is released into the
cell in the case of corona viruses this
piece of RNA travels to our own cells
ribosome and hijacks them to create its
own viral proteins an interesting thing
I learned making this video is that this
viral RNA is capable of shifting the
three-letter frame of RNA bases that's
read by the ribosome this essentially
doubles the peptide sequences that can
be made from one single strand of viral
RNA viral translation using our
ribosomes makes the proteins that the
virus needs to assemble additional
copies of itself which will eventually
be released from the cell and infect
other cells there's an important protein
that's translated in this process and
that's the main protease that cleaves
the viral polypeptide chain into the
functional proteins needed to assemble
new viruses this is another therapeutic
target if an individual is already
infected with the virus but you can
administer a drug that binds to the
protease and stops it from creating
mature viral proteins viral replication
can be slowed this main Tsarskoe of two
protease is a dimer made up of two
identical protein chains and it must
dimerize to become a functional protease
there are many amino acid interactions
at the dimer interface but the
researchers that publish this crystal
structure suggests that the ionic
interactions between the sidechain of
this arginine residue and this glutamate
drive the dimerization this interaction
is present on both sides of the dimer
moving over to the active site the
important residues are this cysteine
side chain and this histidine this
enzyme is a cysteine protease so it uses
the nucleophilic cysteine to attack the
amat bond of a peptide in the mechanism
the histidine nitrogen grabs the proton
off cysteine side chain allowing it to
attack the peptide bond the peptide bond
is cleaved and then a water molecule can
come in releasing cysteine so that the
protease can cleave another polypeptide
enzymes containing nucleophilic
catalytic residues are excellent targets
for irreversible inhibition because they
contain a nucleophilic amino acid side
chain cysteine in this case inhibitors
can be designed that bind to the enzyme
with a permanent covalent bond unlike
reversible inhibitors that can pop in
and out of an active site
these irreversible also called suicide
inhibitors permanently inactivate the
enzyme preventing it from doing its job
and creating more viral proteins these
researchers had previously designed
inhibitors for other coronavirus
proteases they were able to bind one of
these inhibitors to the active site of
the Czar's co2 protease and that's what
we're looking at here
notice this cysteine is clearly involved
in a covalent bond with the ketone of
the inhibitor now this is a reversible
reaction so this isn't a suicide
inhibitor itself but I still think it's
pretty neat to see that cysteine tied up
in a covalent bond in this structure
over here this carbonyl of the inhibitor
is making hydrogen bonds with three
backbone NH groups of the protein the
catalytic histidine of the protease is
also involved in a hydrogen bond
this ring over here is involved in an
extensive hydrogen bonding Network
involving both backbone atoms and side
chains knowing the contacts an inhibitor
makes with an enzyme allows chemists and
biologists to consider the interactions
and potentially design even better
inhibitors because kovat 19 infection is
particularly harmful to the lungs this
research group administered the
inhibitor directly into the lungs of
mice by inhalation the mice did not
suffer adverse effects from this
treatment and so this could potentially
lead to promising Cova 19 treatments in
the future every new piece of
information we learn about viruses leads
us to a better understanding of disease
and treatment you might be wondering
what you can do at a time like this
first of all if videos like this
interests you keep at it work on your
understanding of disease and structure
so that you can be part of the cure in
the future
follow the hygiene and social distancing
guidelines not only to prevent getting
the disease but to slow the spread of
Kovan 19 so that we can keep our
researchers and the health care workers
on the frontlines safe and be sure to
take care of your own mental health
reach out to friends and family by phone
text video chat spend time on your
hobbies get some exercise we're going to
need that awesome brain of yours in the
future so take good care of it